what you see here in blue this is the
graph of y is equal to f of x
where f of x is equal to
x to the third minus six x squared plus
x minus five
what i want to do in this video
is think about what is the equation of
the tangent line when x is equal to 1 so
we can visualize that
so this is x equaling 1 right over here
this is the value of the function when x
is equal to one right over there and
then the tangent line looks something
like
will look something like i know i can do
a better job than that it's going to
look something like that
and what we want to do is find the
equation
the equation of that line and if you are
inspired i encourage you to be pause the
video and try to work it out
well the way that we could do this is if
we find the derivative at x equals 1 the
derivative is the slope of the tangent
line and so we'll know the slope of the
tangent line and we know that it
contains that point and then we can use
that to find the equation of the tangent
line so let's actually just let's just
so we want the equation of the tangent
line when x is equal to one so let's
just first of all evaluate f of one
so f of one
is equal to
one to the third power which is one
minus 6 times 1 squared so it's just
minus 6
and then plus 1
plus 1
minus 5. so this is equal to what
2 minus 11
which is equal to
negative 9. and that looks about right
that looks like about negative 9 right
over there the scales are different on
the y and the x axis and so that is f of
1. it is
negative 9. did i do that right this is
negative 5 negative yep negative 9. and
now let's evaluate what the derivative
is at 1.
so
what is f prime of x
f
prime of x
well here it's just a polynomial
take the derivative of x to the third
well we
apply the power rule we bring the three
out front so you get three x to the and
then we go one less than three to get
the second power
then you have
minus 6x squared so you bring the 2
times the 6 to get 12. so minus 12
x
to the well 2 minus 1 is 1 power so
that's the same thing as 12x and then
plus
the derivative of x is just 1
that's just going to be 1. and if you
view this as x to the first power we're
just bringing the 1 out front and
decrement decrementing the 1. so it's 1
times x to the 0 power which is just 1.
and then the derivative of a constant
here is just going to be 0. so this is
our derivative of f and if we want to
evaluate it at 1 f prime
of 1 is going to be 3 times 1 squared
which is just 3 minus 12 times 1 so it's
just minus 12 and then we have plus
1.
so this is 3 minus 12 is negative 9 plus
1 is equal to
negative 8. so we know the slope right
over here is a slope of negative 8. we
know a point on that line it contains
the point 1 comma negative 9 so we could
use that information to find the
equation of the line the line just to
remind ourselves has the form y is equal
to mx
plus b where m is the slope so we know
that y is going to be equal to negative
eight x plus b
and now we can substitute the x and y
value that we know sits on that line to
solve for b so we know that y is equal
to negative nine let me just write this
here y is equal to negative nine when x
is equal to
when x is equal to 1.
and so we get
we get
negative 9 is equal to negative 8 times
1 so negative 8
plus
v
well let's see you could we could add we
could add 8 to both sides and we get
negative 1 is equal to b so we're done
the equation of the line the equation of
this line that we have in magenta right
over there
that is
y
is equal to the slope
is negative 8x and then the y-intercept
minus 1.